hello everybody and welcome to part 13
of let's play from dusk all right
we're gonna get a move on here go go go
because there's explosions and volcanoes
and why build that right next to a
volcano why what is then what is the
intelligence of that nothing I say
nothing at all anyway we're moving on
here ladies leading the pack
oh hello beautiful how you doing yeah
whoo that's Purdy that's Purdy all right
man I think the ancients are just
playing some sick game with these people
what are you doing lagging behind get
move on I know yeah you're you're
bashful or whatnot I don't know but get
a move on get the lead out is lava
like right there you must be that badass
from the last round oh you better move
lady
I feel bad okay amplify the breath oh
boy all right I don't know okay let's
see if I can get people to hear cuz I
imagine the most important thing first
off is not letting them all die okay
good you move just in time god you
couldn't have cut that closer whatever
aah like you're almost as much of a
badass as I am all right the lava flow
hopefully that stops soon maybe I could
maybe maybe I could maybe I could make
the flow go the other way down the
mountain that'd probably be good oh not
a tsunami
Alyssia I bet I bet I could do this yeah
I better could I mean things are so
manipulative in this game that I mean I
don't see why not
yeah yeah that's solved that problem
I'll solve that problem right up yeah
all right um I don't know where my envoy
to that repelled lava is but oh oh no no
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] ah oh I did not I
did not account for this I did not
account for that Oh scheisse that's why
these are here that's why I need to use
them I need to be smarter but huh dumb
Oh mark
whatever whatever oh that's just gonna
flood yeah never mind forget it forget
it that's just gonna cause a cascade of
water and flood everyone whatever better
than burning alive I say okay now let's
see
I've almost got that volcano completely
stopped up her not stopped up in these
but at least going the other way what
where did you come from
what the hell damn it what who's who
needs help you oh man
lady is still you the badass from before
you go girl
I gotcha I gotcha yeah no need to thank
me I know I'm amazing
Oh boom oh not even a little bit of a
problem oh no not another volcano oh no
I must stop volcano amplified my breath
my breath is so great Oh
I chew bubblegum and whatnot
I use your own lava against you how do
you like that oh you don't too bad
all right almost almost almost ah more
and more help I'm a little busy here
trying to stop everyone from dying okay
almost there
amplify the breath again give me that
now but now over okay a little bit at a
time cuz it doesn't melt okay
there okay all right I don't think
that's gonna go down that way just yet
all right but this is a still a problem
cuz I don't know how people are gonna
get to here but I don't know maybe they
can try man oh no oh no oh no I think
she died oh I know oh no are you coming
from over there
that's a different lady oh but the other
lady was so badass excuse me oh sorry
throat still bad but we'll push forward
because I am hardcore Oh can they get to
this one
Oh infinite earth I could definitely use
infinite earth right now come on please
get there in time rather there's gonna
be a tsunami there's gonna be death and
destruction everywhere come on Lady you
can make it oh man
the other one didn't and I feel bad
about that I'm like I'm like very
personally connected with people when
they die except you know when I'm I'm
the cause but you know
I don't like death when you know when I
can prevent it and if I'm forced to kill
that I even legging the left dr. Emma
Belle Swanson is it is an example I felt
terrible after that you should probably
know I'm the type of guy that always
plays the good morality stuff like that
I usually do like yeah I'm just so nice
awesome and tough that I don't feel the
need to be evil yeah oh no no the secret
of water figure the water oh no it was
so close
the secret of water was so close oh man
that's bad
oh oh people are screaming oh people are
screaming ohh people screaming yes and
someone from there because oh no oh no
no oh man can i dam this up maybe I can
infinite earth with amplify breath okay
yeah yeah forgot how powerful that was
yeah get just go the other way
oh yeah you got nothing on this yeah out
of here
what is that just a stream why isn't
that going away alright I'll try again
don't know what that's all about but I
will put a stop to it
go cool infinite earth and amplify
breath recharge quick come on now
too much soil can block it how about
infinite amount that cut it for you get
out of here oh no people are burning
people are burning up all while people
burning up I need that I need you to
survive for the infinite earth ah oh no
oh no oh oh good gosh oh no oh no oh no
they're still fire they're still fire
they're still fired no not dirt not
right now dirt I don't have time oh boy
oh boy oh boy okay ah [ __ ] stupid fire
oh hey you Oh fire oh I feel bad are
there even enough people left to
repopulate that one I hope so I hope so
I did not do a good enough job blocking
that up I got it I got a check myself
before I wreck myself
amplified out-breath yeah
okay
okay all right build that up nice and
high
okay just go completely the other way
now please all right Wow this yeah the
ancients were idiots all of them
oh man oh no no no no no no no not get
saved saved saved saved oh why is it
still on fire okay right there we go Oh
No the village I destroyed it anyway why
can I not help these people
oh man I am a I'm a bad bad bad deity
okay I need to build a bigger wall here
okay you almost got the infinite are the
amplified breath again oh these have got
to go cuz they're not helping at all
alright almost yeah bang those drums
okay here we go okay getting that nice
and high so that people do not die all
I'm so good like I am from the hood on
okay click this finally stopped up
because this refuses to stop up in some
reason there we go okay oh cool it's
draining off into an abyss that leads to
nowhere probably off the map
okay good Wow I actually stopped that up
cool good for me probably won't stand up
to a tsunami but at least it's something
something to put some hope into these
people's bleak and meagre lives I mean
really maybe I could stop this up
let me try oh hello
oh no that did not do it that didn't do
it that did not do it oh oh oh no oh no
oh no oh no that did oh it was bad so
that all those bad though that you
because even doesn't let on Oh get out
of here oh wow
why did I do that white why why why did
I do that oh that was the worst thing I
could possibly have done okay okay okay
all right
crisis uh shiitake mushrooms ah [ __ ] now
okay oh I royally buggered everything up
oh they're all dying oh man oh I'm not
gonna let you oh no wall of death oh
[ __ ] everyone's everyone's dead okay um
I'm gonna cut it here and try to oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] I'm gonna cut it here and try to
recover some of the something oh god I
did bad I did bad okay thanks so much
for watching I'll see you guys in the
next part where things won't be so bleak
and I won't have killed everyone oh [ __ ]
there it is
damn it alright thanks so much for
watching I'll see you in the next part
bye bye